I got my head crushed in and I went into
the deepest sleep I've I've been in
[Music]
you it's good to be alive
Pascal gets in the hot seat and takes us
back to filming his character's demise
on Game of Thrones
what are the mechanics of shooting a
scene where your character has his eyes
gouged out of his skull
um maybe in this interview as well time
only time I could beg you to gouge my
eyes out and uh collapse my skull in
case it gets really bad the prince of
Dorne himself is put to the spicy test
on hot ones that well oh no and breaks
down his breakout role
shouldn't drink before a fight I always
drink before a fight I can't give
anything away about season four you can
always open a book and inside the George
R.R Martin Song of Ice and Fire a
gruesome moment that inspired one of the
most infamous TV deaths of all time
[Applause]
I I win with the grossest death don't I
yeah Pedro wears that Crown but that
said he has fond memories of filming the
eye-catching moment it was so hot when
we were shooting that scene you know
he's over me and he puts his thumbs into
my eyes there were all of these
fleshy bits that they were
kind of placing all over my face and
pumping blood so that it would pool you
know and spread through the amphitheater
for this like good wide and that sort of
shot of the two of us from above I was
dead asleep that's right while over in
Martel faced a brutal on-screen ending
Pedro was catching some z's on the set
because it was like it was so hot and
this stuff was so cooling to the touch
and you had to be really really still
and knowing also that we had gotten to
the end of this sort of four day fight
that we were shooting out there
um it was a very uh cathartic and I went
into the deepest sleep I've I've been in
[Applause]
it's the most disgusting anyway so
gentle like the gentlest guy ever felt
no pressure at all you know and he was
so hyper aware of it he couldn't even
feel his weight on me as he like you
know basically straddled me and that
actor Pedro kinda got his revenge at the
premiere of got's final season
as you can see I had no fun
there's no personality in this cast at
all I realize now that because I'm not a
very good sleeper I need I need to be
laid out with pieces of Flesh
um gelatinous cool to the touch uh
face meat
and uh pulling blood and maybe I'll
finally get a good night's sleep we're
all dying to see it
[Music]